salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien je suis hyper content de
revenir sur Youtube avec cette série sur
Ragnar le breton c'est un acteur
humoriste que j'ai pu suivre pendant
plusieurs mois au moment où il a décidé
de lancer son spectacle de stand-up mais
aussi de rentrer dans une cage de MMA
pour un combat professionnel la série
est en 4 épisodes il y en aura un
diffusé chaque semaine sur la chaîne
Youtube de brut et pour les plus
impatients sachez que l'intégralité de
la série et d'ores et déjà disponible
dans la brut je vous mets un lien en
description voilà installez-vous
confortablement bon visionnage bonsoir à
tous pour vous annoncer que Daniel que
je devais affronter lors de la
restreinte ce jeudi 9 Mars vient
officiellement d'annuler notre combat
pour des raisons de blessures moi j'ai
sacrifié ma vie pour ça pendant quatre
mois là tu vois j'ai annulé mes
spectacles j'ai refusé des films j'ai
décalé des tournages j'ai fait 180 km
allez 180 km retour tous les jours de la
semaine j'ai moins vu mes enfants j'ai
moins vu ma femme je me suis sacrifié
[Applaudissements]
là je suis content
alors tu es prêt
là on est où là
bien sûr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi Ragnar veut rentrer dans la
cage je pense que c'est pour ça que tu
es là
pour y répondre en tout cas moi j'en ai
aucune idée
[Musique]
c'est la première fois en France où il y
a quelqu'un une vraie étape personnalité
bien installée qui rentre dans la cage
pour un vrai combat il a beaucoup à
peine il a une carrière de comédien
se retrouver à se prendre une branlée
devant toute la France
tocard fini quoi
il y a des années-lumière de tous les
mecs qui s'entraînent aujourd'hui et qui
combattent à Arès sinon tu peux prendre
des tenues ko monstrueux et puis avoir
des séquelles la vie c'est pas un jeu
quoi
[Applaudissements]
de fusil dans les bras il envoie une
frappe c'est mort c'est fini tu dors
il y a des trucs qui me donne des
frissons des fois quand je regarde des
combats quand il m'a dit ils sont hors
d'eux ils sortent d'eux ils sont le ils
sont en état second tu vois j'ai envie
de le ressentir ça
il a pas besoin de combattre le gars
c'est ces tripes il a envie de prouver
qu'il peut le faire j'ai envie de le
faire donc je le ferai toutes ces
difficultés qu'il a eu dans son enfance
son adolescence et tout tu vois c'est ça
qui lui a donné de la force de devenir
qu'il est aujourd'hui j'ai besoin de me
prouver des choses aussi peut-être
je pense que ça va être une thérapie
pour moi
[Musique]
mais du coup ça m'intéresse de voir
votre avis sur le combat
j'aimerais bien la connaître il y a une
blessure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok mon frangin allez bisous
je vous [__]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va Paris
avant de commencer le spectacle je
précise quelque chose de très important
c'est un rôle que je joue parce que
j'étais à Lille la semaine dernière en
plein spectacle
[Applaudissements]
je sais même plus qui je suis sur un
coup je suis un facho un coup je suis un
islamo gauchiste
c'est bon pour vous on y va
ecoute moi je suis producteur de cinéma
et je préparais un film et je cherchais
le convertis un converti bien chaud
qu'il fasse un peu flipper tout le monde
et on me dit dans Paris on me dit ah
mais il y a un grand blond qu'on a vu il
a fait un peu de théâtre mais c'est une
grosse baraque il peut faire l'affaire
un mec impressionnant physiquement mais
quand même temps qui est ce petit truc
cette petite viscomika qui fait que
[__] tu prends pas au sérieux il est
en même temps il est effrayant et
ridicule
[Applaudissements]
il est impressionnant il joue bien et
même quand il s'énerve ça reste drôle
façon Paris ça reclame avec des goûts
forts
s'il te plaît à la fin de ce téléfilm
j'avais demandé à tous les comédiens de
faire un petit peu de promotion et puis
Ragnar fait sa petite vidéo
peut-être un peu appuyé je vous
l'accorde et là il fait 300 minutes
c'est une comédie mais pas que ça veut
dire qu'ils ont ils vont voir que les
musulmans peuvent rigoler peuvent
pleurer peuvent être solidaires peuvent
douter peuvent se disputer incroyable ce
sont des êtres humains et je veux dire
il faut que tu te lances sur les réseaux
là couloir à prendre là tu vois et puis
ce [__] sans rien dire il débarquent
deux semaines après il dit ça y est j'ai
mon compte insta je regarde Ragnar le
Breton ah non à la con alors comment ça
marche ce truc là salut à sa famille
ouais ça m'a plu je trouvais ça délire
ok ok
et jour il m'envoie un sketch mais le
sketch il est éclaté au sol il y a tous
les clichés tu vois il y a toutes les
caricatures qu'il faut pas ah c'est
horrible
bonjour bonjour
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va faire
une petite visite
excusez-moi carrément tu dis il sait pas
trompé de voir lui tu vois ce que je
veux dire c'est carrément nul à ce point
tu vois j'ai les vidéos j'ai tous les
dossiers un bouton je peux savoir où
sont tous les criminels de
l'Île-de-France donc alors il est
4K et c'est là regarde
non c'est pas ça
[Musique]
ah c'est nul tu vois donc je n'ose pas
lui dire c'est nul
Dieu alors le sang qu'est-ce que tu en
penses
heureusement je l'avais pas en face tu
vois ça passe frérot ça passe tu vois
sur le coup on disait ça passe je
t'assure que si tu me casse les couilles
et tu réponds à côté je te fous dans la
gueule ça passait pas mais c'est plus
maintenant quand tu leur regardes waouh
[__] tu disais tu as commencé par ça
quoi tu vois et puis il commence à
inventer ce personnage de Michel
bonsoir bienvenue chez le chevalier noir
je rigole bienvenue chez Michel comment
ça Allah tu as pas une clope
salam aleykoum pas de ça ici bonjour
d'accord puis t'arrêter attention les
extrémistes mais je les [__] moi les
extrémistes
et puis pareil ça c'est un sujet et puis
pareil de religion
la religion pour qu'on peut pas en
parler
ils sont super sympas mais pas dans les
comment je fais mon humour si la masse
comprend que c'est de l'humour et que
les 3% d'extrémisme cassent les couilles
ça me dérange pas
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours voulu faire un beau fond
c'est même quand je faisais du théâtre à
l'époque
j'ai toujours voulu faire ce genre de
personnage tu vois qu'est-ce qui te
plaît en Michel
son côté franc parler au fait trop de
bruit il est jeune ça m'a l'adresse je
me mets sur une place handicapées tu es
avec moi
sa violence aussi un peu il peut être un
peu violent
mais à la finale quand même il est c'est
pas quelqu'un de mauvais
[Musique]
mais on n'est pas avoir
pense à ta femme qui t'a trompé avec
désiré le Congolais 1m95 de folie
meurtrière dans le pieu de ta gonzesse
lui a souillé la gueule il t'a pris
toute ta dignité tu sais comment on
t'appelle à la salle Thomas petit cocu
je suis pas cocu tu es une merde mais
merde Thomas tu es une merde oh ta femme
est une [__]
quand tu regardes bien c'est qu'on l'a
fait sans se prendre la tête
c'est à dire qu'en fait moi ça m'est
venu après le truc j'ai dit vas-y tiens
films a changé de faire un truc dans le
ça a été fait sur le
à l'instant sur la rage en fait tu vois
alors il y a pas la prétention que ça
marche ou pas quoi juste pour rigoler
quoi tu vois comme vous avez pu
constater on ne forme pas que des
athlètes on forme aussi des hommes ah
c'est ce qui te plaît dans cette salle
là ici c'est quelqu'un qui est
complètement con ça rigole tu vois c'est
le bon délire tu peux parler de sujet de
société tu parlais de couple tu veux
parler de de sport d'amour de discussion
de copains tu vois c'est une salle de
sport
c'est pas que des bourrins qui poussent
il y en a comme des ânes qui sont
complètement gonflés la testo il y en
avait beaucoup tu vois mais socialement
parlant ça raconte pas mal de choses ici
tu vois
il se débrouille qui a pris une table
dans la gueule c'est vrai j'hésite à pas
mec pour une tarte il me dit si si j'ai
une niche dessus Alan donc
il y avait 8 grammes d'alcool dans le
sang déjà
ça arrive comme ça
il m'appelle ouais je suis je suis à
Monaco là
viens on va faire une vidéo viens on va
faire une vidéo quelle vidéo ah ben tu
vas venir tu vas mettre une gifle qui tu
racontes frère regardez c'est efficace
là où ça a vraiment pété je pense que
c'était quand qu'elle a été partagé sur
Twitter et que les gens ils savaient pas
si c'était un personnage ou il le
faisait exprès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais descendre je vais t'enculer
[Musique]
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
il n'a pas de parti pris tu sois
tchétchène renoi où tu veux de Front
national ou on n'a rien à [__] tu la
prends tu la prends et puis c'est tout
et puis ça fera le même résultat pour
tout le monde Michel Venom pour un
niveau tuto de self-défense donc là on a
découvertes
ça va
humour on déconne dans les secondes
[Applaudissements]
ça va l'élève jardinier
Leroy Merlin le jardin
[Musique]
c'est juste que tu t'es mélangé et tu
t'y perds donc voilà c'était le breton
on y va on a pas le temps let's go on
bosse
le but c'est de toucher ne passerait
toucher vous allez devoir compter sur
les déplacements interrompre derrière
j'avance je touche et je recule tu lis
ton allant tu te rapproche trop matière
là tu as dit ça
c'est bien Mathias pense à reculer à un
moment donné voilà si tu ne recule pas
il va marquer les points
Mathias t'attend je te vois t'attends
l'économise pas envie de le réservoir
let's go c'est lui qui t'a contacté pour
faire ce combat absolument c'est lui qui
a une ligne
ce qui m'a plu c'était l'idée de se dire
j'ai pas envie de faire un truc bidon un
one shot juste pour faire un buzz ou
quoi que ce soit j'ai envie de
m'entraîner j'ai envie de faire un
combat de combattre et voir où ça va me
mener parce que j'aime ça et parce que
je pense que je suis bien en Touré je
peux le faire vraiment faire quelque
chose de bien un vrai combat ou j'arrive
à a mes gars avec mon adversaire qui
s'est préparé de son côté et qui est une
belle opposition
et tu as envie de poser la main sur lui
et tu veux faire ça pendant que la main
elle est là il te touche OK je suis sûr
utilise ton annonce
bien la brasse
qu'est-ce qui pousse à vouloir rentrer
dans dans une cage de MMA pour un combat
professionnel
je pense que c'est un défi personnel
pour se rappeler aussi avec moi-même sur
plein de trucs
tu manges que tu cherches
on fabrique de la viande j'ai maigri
c'est plus important moi je fonctionne
comme ça je me dis
j'ai envie de le faire donc je le ferai
je suis toujours fait ça dans ma vie
mais j'ai envie de le faire parce que je
pense que ça va être une thérapie pour
moi est-ce que je suis capable de le
faire
je sais pas ça se trouve la veille je
vais me barrer très bien
je suis parti au Chili dans un 3 étoiles
je vais te laisser tout seul à l'hôtel
tu vois tu sais pas
de passer à la salle Louvain qui il sait
ce qu'il fait quoi tu me demandes de
frapper tu demandes circulaires
moi je n'ai fait plein des bagarres tu
vois des trucs tout seul dans des
parkings avec des mecs autour et tout tu
vois quand j'étais plus jeune
on va le préparer là on va l'amener le
transformer le changer à s'améliorer
pour pouvoir faire un combat
professionnel
il risque de perdre le combat de manière
lamentable
j'ai plus qu'à jouer
on parle de la catégorie de poids lourds
il va combattre les poils tout le monde
peut se prendre une branleur
abri de quoi que ce soit à tout moment
une frappe est un équaliseur une seule
frappe suffit à changer le game
alors le fait qu'il veut rentrer dans la
cage c'est une norme connerie
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que ce premier épisode
vous a plu ou vous a donné au moins
envie de voir la suite pour ceux qui
n'ont pas envie d'attendre la semaine
prochaine je vous rappelle que
l'intégralité des épisodes sont d'ores
et déjà disponibles dans la brut sinon
rendez-vous vendredi prochain à 18h
merci encore pour votre soutien à très
vite et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à
la chaîne Youtube de brut